Yeah.
Like what are you talking about? Like we
can't have a rational conversation if
you're not willing to address that.
Who blew the whistle? An Israeli
reserveist who served three tours of
duty in Gaza has told Sky News that his
unit was often ordered to shoot anyone
entering areas soldiers defined as no-go
zones regardless of whether they posed a
threat. A practice he says left
civilians dead where they fell.
Assalamu alaykum. I really want to thank
Walk forever for partnering with
Abdullah in this absolutely amazing very
very important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. Restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs. People have lost hands and uh
legs. uh some above the knee, some below
the knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example
of Ahmed
Ahmed. Mashallah, he's one of the so
many whom we've been able to assist with
your partnership. So, may Allah reward
you and grant you goodness and may Allah
almighty continue to use all of us to do
this good work.
[Music]
Brothers and sisters, dear friends, Joe
Rogan obviously has been speaking out
against the whole Israel, Gaza
situation, um the not the situation, the
genocide, Damascus that's happening and
it's becoming more and more vocal.
people have realized and the reason why
it took them so long like himself,
Pierce Morgan and the rest is because
the value of the blood of um the western
world and the child with blue eyes,
blonde hair is more valuable than a
Muslim or an Indian or a black whatever
this is and it's subconsciously that's
the reason why it takes longer for them
to realize because they have been
programmed not that they want to some of
them do it intentionally but because
they've been programmed to this is how
they've been made to think that's more
valuable that's not that's why when the
Russian Ukraine. What happened?
Journalists were out coming and saying
this is something that happens in the
Middle East. This is what happens to,
you know, basically the Muslims, you
know, and they get blown to pieces. It's
not that deep. But when it happens to
ours, they were saying this is
catastrophe at a meeting. It's happening
to the white people. But anyways, let's
watch the clips for oursel in how Rogan
he even used the f word. He finds it
absolutely insane. Here's the video in
what he had to say.
Terrible attack.
But also what they've done to Gaza is
insane. And if you can't see that, if
you can't say that and you your response
is Israel has a right to defend itself,
like what are you talking about? against
what children against women and children
that are getting blown apart against aid
workers that are getting killed. It's
insane and no one wants to talk about
it. And if you do talk about it, you're
anti-semitic. It's which is so strange.
Like I don't know how they wrangled
that.
So imagine atrocity happened to myself
and I use that card for the rest of my
life for privileges and whatever I can
and nobody can criticize me etc. And
it's true. It's right you should do you
know if something really bad happened
etc. But then I start to abuse that card
and say no. When I'm bullying people,
killing people and I go no but remember
what happened to my family? It doesn't
work. People are going to say, "Well,
hold on a second. Hold a sec. We know
what happened to your family was bad,
but now you are taking the mick." And
that's exactly what's happening. And
when Israelis deny this, look, another
clip of Joe Rogan, which you haven't
seen anywhere else, which I'll uh show
you guys in. Check this out as well in
the late 60s, but it was, you know, you
would get attacked. And I think now
people realize like that was the correct
response. And I think in the future
people realize the correct response is
like this is not
Yeah. October 7th was awful. Absolutely.
So just stop there. What he's talking
about is the Vietnam War in the 1960s.
He's saying back then people saying no
it was justified etc whatever now
they're saying no we should have not
gone to that that shouldn't have
happened that was that was that was do
you get what I'm trying to say
subjectivity subjective morality it's
changed over time and that was wrong
he's saying that back then people would
justify the Vietnam war now they're
saying no it was wrong
but also what they've done to Gaza is
insane and if you can't see that if you
can't say that and you your response is
Israel has a right to defend itself like
what are you talking about against what
children against women and children that
are getting blown apart against aid
workers that are getting killed like
what are you talking about like we can't
have a rational conversation if you're
not willing to address that.
Yeah, I think their heart is hardened.
If if I'm trying to be as chatable as as
possible, like um the Israelis
specifically maybe from the October 7
what they saw there, their heart is
hardened and I think a lot of people
especially on the uh Republican side,
they're unable to see the Palestinians
as
as as humans, especially as uh as as
people with emotions and feelings and
and and all of that. And
imagine that was happening in
Scandinavia, you know.
Yeah. Right.
Yeah. Exactly. It's very strange.
My kid um my 5-year-old uh kid uh
Exactly. I mean there you go Bron says
and not only that when you look at the
Harro newspaper Bron says what does it
say it's a killing field IDF soldiers
ordered to shoot deliberately at the
unarmed gardens waiting for humanitarian
aid that singer came and said death to
the IDF okay and people lost their mind
he was talking about who like if you
look at from his perspective talking
about freedom of speech he's talking
about an arm that's committing genocide
if I said death death to ISIS
anyone Yeah, of course. And and should I
be honest with you, Allah say that all
day every day, death to them, death to
ISIS all day every day. I know that the
prophet Muhammad peace told us to if you
catch these people, not like literally,
but to get rid of them ISIS. Why?
Because they are a biggest threat to
world peace, one of those. Yes. So if I
said death, death to ISIS, fine. Death,
death to Russian army, fine, no problem.
Death death to IDF, no. Nah. Number one,
it's my curtailing my freedom of speech.
Number two, it is an active army that's
committing genocide. If anyone said
death to ISIS, would anyone come and say
that's a hemophobic? You're trying to
hate Muslims. No one would ever say
that. And not only that, Muslims have
condemned ISIS. But here you've got
Harrett, the newspaper in Israel saying
that these guys are openly shooting. And
not only that, forget that. I've got
another evidence. Yes. Uh from a video
from the Young Turks. Okay, go. Let's uh
show this in. Watch this.
Soldier who blew the whistle. An Israeli
reservist who served three tours of duty
in Gaza has told Sky News that his unit
was often ordered to shoot anyone
entering areas soldiers defined as no-go
zones regardless of whether they posed a
threat. A practice he says left
civilians dead where they fell. We have
a territory that we are in. And the
commands are everyone that comes inside
needs to die. If they're inside, they're
dangerous and you need to kill them no
matter who it is. He said troops killed
civilians arbitrarily and that the
criteria for whether or not to open fire
on civilians varied depending on the
commander. They might be shot, they
might be captured. It really depends on
the day, the mood of the commander.
Every commander can choose for himself
what he does. So, it's kind of like the
wild west. So, some commanders can
really decide to do war crimes and bad
things and don't face the consequences
of that. The soldier described a
prevailing belief among troops that all
gazins were terrorists, even when they
were clearly unarmed civilians. This
perception, he said, was not challenged
and was often endorsed by commanders.
So, there you go. From the IDF's mouth,
and this is where you can see the
hypocrisy. Yes. When a singer says
death, death the IDF. Oh, hell no. All
hell breaks loose. But the idea of
soldiers themselves committing massacre
on a global scale. Men, women, children,
people are going to get food. But that
there you can't say nothing. This is the
hypocrisy of of the western world. They
are strategically consistent, not
morally. And Islam teaches that we are
morally consistent, not strategically.
We say innocent killing killing innocent
people, it is absolutely haram. And that
is the stark difference. You see when
ISIS were committing atrocities, killing
Muslims and killing innocent people, we
as Muslims from your lay man Muslim who
works in 9 to5 to whoever it is like
myself, another lay man, public figures,
imams, scholars, we all condemned
because our religion calls it to you've
got from the bottom up idea to the
Zionist supporting it fully. That's all
I'm going to say, brother. Inshallah.
May Allah bless and preserve you guys.
Big up to Joe Rogan even though it's a
little bit late but still at least he's
speaking out against it. to lie over
their head.